[Music]
the theme of this year's Singapore
design week is better by Design in
celebration of design Singapore cil's
20th anniversary it spotlights the go
purposeful Spirit of Singapore design
and the desire always to seek and make
lives better using design it's the first
time the Singapore design wiek is
activating the bras basa kis Design
District with immersive experiences that
is weing walking distance the three
specially comination exhibitions
highlights some of today's problems
through looking at them from different
lenses of design that includes
Innovation sustainability and
inclusivity field is a Showcase of new
projects in inclusive design from across
different design disciplines visitors
can enjoy a range of interactive
experiences for bodies of all mobilities
where we really welcome you know the
full range of creativity from my
diversity of human bodies and Minds the
show is divided into five key areas
there's fun care the emotions the senses
and the social and for example in the
area for fun we've invented a gaming
platform that allows people to play
together regardless of their
abilities when it comes to
sustainability the learning never stops
at school or tomorrow the students will
learn about environmental issues in a
fun and nostalgic way we have 10 classes
covering from Humanities to sciences and
more in a bio class we will show how
plastic has polluted our food chain and
we'll be introducing new bioplastics and
new bio composite in our math class we
will see how habits add up in our
interactive carbon footprint calculator
other than academic subjects we have
home eons PE canteen and even a SI Bay
I'm happy to report here that there are
no exams at the school of Tomorrow
playground of possibilities showcases 12
different design stories of
possibilities that looks at problems of
today and uses innovative ways to solve
these problems visitors can expect to
see an experience immersive playscape
with experiential installations where we
have four keywords explore empathize
imagine and adapt we really hope that
visitors to the show will see that
inclusive design is not just good for
people with additional needs but really
that it can make a better world for
everybody with this exhibition we hope
we can bring A New Perspective to our
visitors to show them how sustainability
is so important to our daily Liv
everyone can have fun at this sandbox of
creativity and to see how we can use
design to create a better world come
join us at the bras basa boogies Design
District for Sparks of inspiration and
where the impact of design comes to
[Music]
life